Number 5: Vikings.
What would a Viking be without his faithful combat helmet, with those impressive horns?
The answer is simple: a more historically correct Viking.
Just think of the usefulness of wearing a helmet in combat. Through the horns
on the helmet it is very easy to remove the head protection.
Or, if you have a strap on your helmet, your opponent has a good hold on you
throw it on the ground and then cut your throat.
Helmets with horns is a terrible idea. That is also the reason that archaeologists have never found such helmets
at Viking battlefields. And there is also no evidence that they wore this.
They were poets and artists - people who don't care about the actual facts -
who gave Vikings a stupid helmet at the end of 1800. Long after the Vikings made this mistake
could not straighten out.
Number 4: Lady Godiva.
The story of this English noble lady from the eleventh century is that her husband, also the count, raised taxes
in the town of Coventry. Lady Godiva found this too high and, not surprisingly, the residents thought it too.
She teased her husband with the promise that she would ride naked in the city for in exchange
that he would lower taxes. He agreed, annoyed, without knowing that she would do this, but the opposite was true.
Because people don't like taxes, even though it pays for life,
the story of Lady Godiva is continued by incorporating it into logos and music.
While Lady Godiva has really lived and Coventry is a real city, there is none
only proof that naked riding really happened. So we can assume that the story is incorrect.
Just like with the Viking helmet, it is again the fault of the poets and artists who made this story
made up after the death of Lady Godiva.
Number 3: Napoleon.
This famous tiny general, perhaps it was to compose his height,
took control of France, expanded the influence of the empire, and appointed himself emperor.
The official length of Napoleon was 5'2 inches (1.58 m). But in this time the French inches were longer
than the English inches. So actually Napoleon's height should be indicated in England
are as 5'7 inches (1.70 m). What is fairly small today,
but in early 1800 this length was average.
Anyway, England, with his eternal love for everything that is French, it didn't matter
and made their own "Napoleon-is-so-small-HAHA" story in newspapers and cartoons.
In the meantime, Napoleon was busy introducing the metric system in France and the rest of the world
and standardize it so that such mistakes would no longer be made.
Fortunately, the whole world uses this system. Almost the whole world, sort of ...
Number 2: Roman vomit
Aah, the Roman Empire. Large and powerful. Only decayed by the decadence from within.
And what could be a better example of this decadence than the vomitorium? Here where the Romans, after themselves
crammed full of good food, could vomit to eat themselves completely around again.
Vomitoria really existed, but the idea behind it is not true. It is understandable
that confusion arises. The name "vomit-orium" ("vomit" is vomiting) seems to clarify the purpose.
Even though you can do Latin for some reason - probably because you live in a country that
necessarily want to waste hundreds of hours learning a dead, useless language - this knowledge
won't help you. "Vomitum" means "spit out".
So what's real? If you ever went to a big stadium, say,
that of the Romans. Then you have already used the vomitorium. This is what the vomitorium is.
A large entrance and exit that allows a large amount of people through. The people are emerging
be spit. Not the content of the people.
Number 1: Columbus.
There is so much wrong with the story being told about Christopher Columbus,
it's hard to start where. But the biggest misconception is that everyone thought
that the world was flat instead of round. Columbus was the only smart guy who knew the earth was just around.
It's a good story. Only people have known since about 5,000 BC. that the earth had a spherical shape.
6,500 years before Columbus goes on a sailing trip. And this knowledge has never been since
lost in the West. In 200 BC. Eratosthenes calculated the perimeter
of Earth and this calculation were still used in the time of Columbus.
The discussion between Columbus and Queen Isabella was not about the shape, but about the size of the earth.
Columbus estimated the earth to be much smaller than Queen Isabella and her scientific advisors.
That's why Columbus thought he could easily sail across the empty Atlantic to India.
But Columbus' estimation was incorrect, just like Napoleon's length, this was due to different units of measurement.
However, with his mistake he came to the west. Where he was the first European to discover America,
as long as you ignore the hornless Vikings that were him 500 years ago.
Translated into Dutch: Samuel Arrascaeta Report errors in the comments below. :)